[Music]
hello everyone this is Pete also known
as now though here to give you guys a
little bit of information about this
this game called godhood it is from a B
games which is a Dutch studio the the
game is about a civilization who is
worshipping a god and the civilization
you plays the god essentially and you're
taking over more cities and other areas
to get followers to make your your
followers and your religion if you will
better than everybody else's religion
now when you start the game you pick
between different types of virtues I
decided to pick the war won but they
also had a type of virtue that allowed
you to convert them over to your side
you had another one through love yet
another and then you have three others
and I want to pick the violent one the
hate one if you will or the war one
that's what it's called war because I
wanted to see how the combat ended up
being and the combat was very very
interesting now that brings me into the
type of gameplay that this game is the
gameplay for it is you've had your own
town and in that town you end up placing
different monuments and you end up
placing all of the different things that
your followers are gonna need now you
start with one I guess stronger follower
that ends up being one of your warriors
and that one warrior ends up then
recruiting other warriors and then those
other warriors are then trained through
different types of offerings and
different types of combat to to make
them grow
now what I ended up learning through
this is that I went from one town to
another town with my with my my
followers and having them grow stronger
and get this XP called morale once that
morale level was full you ended up then
allowing them to get more specialized
skills for instance you were able to get
a you know +1 to might or +1 to to
courage and +1 to entangle and things
like that that allowed you to change the
the the way that that person's path was
going to make them stronger now the they
had multiple different class roles
within that and that's where your your
virtues from the beginning take place
now if you wanted to do everything as
the war you want to pick more of the
violent characters if you wanted to pick
more of the convert' classes you pick
the more convert classes to change
everybody over so what I ended up doing
was as my playthroughs I ended up
picking different types of classes just
cuz I wanted to see how they different
they played and when you ended up
getting those characters stronger you
ended up learning that some ended up
making others stronger for instance the
shield guide that you ended up picking
the ended up being like a Guardian class
would end up blocking for weaker classes
and then you would end up having the
druid class which would then end up
buffing the the shield class and you'd
end up going back and forth and this is
very weird dynamic from class to class
and it made the game very very unique
now what was very surprising was I I
remember playing this game called
black and white back in the the early
2000 late you know 1990s and
I thought it was gonna be based on the
same thing you had a religion you headed
up bringing your followers and your
worshippers and all that and you ended
up producing a group and then you'd go
and then you'd you know attack a town
that's what I thought this was gonna be
and that was clearly mistaken so when I
ended up taking the the best villages
over when I was going through a little
by little it ended up just My gods like
image appearing on each of the each of
the color of the villages and I mean
there really wasn't much to it except it
took me a little bit of time to you know
make sure that my guys were rested and
and make sure that their their offerings
were right and May and make sure all of
these things were done correctly now
after those things were done after I was
able to do that I actually got a
notification that one of my characters
were too old and then I looked down I
realized that each of them had an age
also involved and once they hit a
certain age they ended up becoming
weaker and then I ended up kind of
looking more into it and then I realized
oh not only do they have an age they
have a a like a faith bar and your faith
bar ended up making your character even
stronger to being able to hit early on
like combat quicker or slower and it was
kind of interesting
now the graphics of this game was
actually very good they were very very
much
Trudie for the most part but once you
would go into that combat it was almost
like a 3d type look and I really liked
it I thought it was good now for me
wanting to replay it I had a problem
getting off of it I really wanted to
keep playing I keep finishing I was able
to complete the first island that I was
about to go to the second island that I
tried it got destroyed and you'll see
that in the video I'm gonna make sure I
put that in so you guys can see it it's
not an easy game and that's what made me
kind of think about it I was like wait a
minute
this isn't just an easy just roll
through type game because in the
beginning once I realized how the
classes worked and realizing that one
elements would you know make another
element weaker like life would attack
darkness and there's so many there was
about six or seven it almost felt like
Pokemon with how many different types of
elements you had to you know know what
was going on and I made sure that I kind
of used them to see how they worked and
it was pretty cool it worked out really
well
the the end result of the of the first
map I wasn't a hundred percent positive
on but the the villages when I completed
the vit like when I cook over the
villages I got followers I got
worshipers but some of them ended up
also having buffs that allows you to get
increased to might or increase to faith
or increased to characters coming in and
after you complete some of them you
could even get relics which would end up
boosting your characters so would make
that there might stronger or there like
when they would rest in town more
followers and things like that which was
which was very interesting I would
definitely recommend this game to people
with that wanted to take a game that
they want to play and just shut off
their brains and go I really enjoyed it
I really liked it
it wasn't what I was expecting and I
think that was a good thing because I
ended up just enjoying the environments
which would really neat the the
placement of your village which you were
able to get a monastery you put it here
you get a farm you put it here you get a
what was the other one the hen house you
put it there you'd be able to place them
all over and then you'd end up using
those like I said before to increase
your your characters which was very neat
so there you also had you also created
your own gods look in the beginning
which I wasn't expecting it was kind of
cool
bars moved back and forth you picked up
colors it was great it was fun so I
would like to thank Abbi games once
again for this this key it like I said
this game was great uh you know if you
want to pick it up it's definitely one
of those you know go out and get it
relax chill and have it have a fun
evening so once again this is Pete also
known as now though here for the iron
Lords podcasts stream team we have our
podcast on Sundays at 1:00 p.m. so come
on check us out thank you very much and
have a
you
you
you
you